obtengamos un poco de práctica
resolviendo ecuaciones
digamos por ejemplo que tenemos la
ecuación un tercio más
igual a cinco tercios y aquí lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar cuánto vale
a que tenemos que encontrar qué número
si sumamos un tercio más ese número nos
queda cinco tercios y bueno pues hay
muchísimas formas de encontrar cuánto
vale a de hecho esta es una de las cosas
más divertidas acerca de las ecuaciones
que no hay una forma estricta de cómo se
tienen que hacer las cosas pero bueno
aunque se puede hacer de muchas formas
ahorita te voy a enseñar una forma que
yo creo que es la forma más simple de
encontrar este valor
y como siempre cuando estemos haciendo
un ejercicio ponle pausa al vídeo e
intenta resolverlo por tu cuenta y ya
después ves cómo lo hice yo
yo cuando veo una ecuación como estas
como quiero encontrar el valor de a lo
que me gustaría hacer es dejar a la a
solita de un lado del igual y como la a
ya está del lado izquierdo del igual
entonces pues lo que me gustaría hacer
es encontrar alguna forma de deshacerme
de este un tercio y la mejor forma que
se me ocurre para deshacerme de este más
un tercio es restarle un tercio ahora
esto es algo muy importante
no puedo simplemente llegar y restarle
un tercio al lado izquierdo de esta
ecuación aunque porque aquí tenemos que
un tercio más a es igual a cinco tercios
y si yo llego y le restó un tercio
únicamente a esta parte a un tercio más
a entonces esto de aquí va a ser un
tercio más chico mientras que cinco
tercios se queda exactamente igual
entonces pues el lado izquierdo
ya no va a ser igual al lado derecho de
hecho va a ser menor aunque iba a ser un
tercio menor entonces para preservar la
igualdad y para que el lado izquierdo
siga siendo igual al lado derecho lo que
tengo que hacer es restarle un tercio al
lado derecho también aunque hay todo lo
que le haga al lado izquierdo se lo
tengo que hacer también al lado derecho
para que sigan siendo iguales y entonces
si restó un tercio de los dos lados del
igual que me queda pues un tercio menos
un tercio es cero y entonces me queda
simplemente a del lado izquierdo
mientras que del lado derecho tenemos
cinco tercios cinco tercios menos un
tercio menos un tercio y ahora si esto a
cuánto es igual pues tenemos cinco
tercios menos un tercio podemos verlo de
esta otra forma tenemos cinco de una
cosa que son
y luego le estamos restando un tercio
así es que nos quedan cuatro de esta
cosa que son tercios que vamos a
escribirlo por aquí a es igual a cuatro
tercios y podemos checar que esto sea
correcto en la ecuación original aunque
un tercio más a tiene que ser igual a
cinco tercios y bueno pues un tercio más
cuatro tercios si son cinco tercios
bueno hagamos más ejercicios como éste
digamos que tenemos que acá menos ocho
es igual a 11.8 así es que otra vez en
esta ecuación quiero encontrar el valor
de cada
y pues para encontrar el valor de que me
está estorbando un poquito esté menos 8
por lo que voy a encontrar la forma de
deshacerme de este menos 8 y que me
quede simplemente un acá del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación y la mejor
forma de deshacerse de este menos 8 es
simplemente sumar 8 pero por supuesto si
le suma 8 al lado izquierdo también le
tengo que sumar 8 al lado derecho
entonces le estamos sumando 8 a los dos
lados de la ecuación del lado izquierdo
tenemos una acá y después restamos 8 y
sumamos 8 y este menos 88 es igual a 0 o
sea que se cancelan y nos queda
simplemente acá y del lado derecho
tenemos 11.88 nunca pero 11 más 8 es 19
entonces nos queda 19.8 y listo ya
terminamos y como es una ecuación
podemos verificar que la respuesta sea
correcta aunque a 19.8 menos 8 si es
igual a 11.8 entonces está bien nuestra
respuesta bueno vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio digamos que tenemos 53 seamos
igual a menos
13 a vos
esto esto se puede ver muy interesante
porque ahora la variable está del lado
derecho de la ecuación
así es que pues vamos a dejarla t por
aquí y vamos a ver si podemos resolver
esta ecuación pero ahora con la variable
del lado derecho
simplemente nos vamos a deshacer de
estos 613 abós y para hacer eso como ya
hemos visto en los otros ejemplos lo
único que tenemos que hacer es sumar 63
de abós pero por supuesto si sumamos 63
seamos del lado derecho de la ecuación
también los tenemos que sumar del lado
izquierdo para que se preserven la
igualdad
y entonces del lado izquierdo tenemos 5
treceavos 513 a vos más 613 a vos
treceavos mientras que del lado derecho
tenemos la variable t y luego menos 613
abós y más 613 abós pero la suma de
estos dos es cero por lo que simplemente
nos queda la variable t ok y 513 a vos
más 613 a voz pues son 11 treceavos así
es que 11 13 a vos es igual a t
también podemos escribirlo como que te
es igual a 11 13 a vos y listo